[Music]
are you ready to have another baby
ready but not quite ready to commit to a
name for that baby yep kylie jenner and
travis scott's baby boy is wolf no more
let us explain it's fun last month the
24 year old beauty mogul announced the
arrival of her and travis's second child
a son whom they named wolf jacques
webster i'm obsessed with it cute
sidebar that middle name is a nod to dad
as fans of the 30 year old grammy winner
know his real name is jacques i love it
but back to the baby formerly known as
wolf on monday kylie posted this short
statement to instagram revealing their
little bundle of joy's name change sort
of never a dull moment
quote fyi our son's name isn't wolf
anymore we just really didn't feel like
it was him just wanted to share because
i keep seeing wolf everywhere
deep down like i would love my true fans
to know
like all my personal stuff kai has yet
to announce what they changed wolf's
name to it's going to be cool but we
have a feeling it will be just as unique
can you give us a hint i can't
the couple first revealed the name of
their newborn son shortly after his
birth when kylie shared this simple
message to her insta story wolf webster
along with a white heart emoji when your
kids your babies have babies it's magic
and while the name change might come as
a surprise the kylie cosmetics founder
may have dropped a hint earlier in the
day when she released a 10 minute vlog
about the baby titled two hour sun
not too wolf
34 weeks today which means they only got
about a month left
four years later because this baby
and you have the same due date
yeah so the you and the baby could have
the same birthday okay february first
you okay with that
yes
okay bye
then again kylie shared a similar video
back in 2018 for the birth of their
first child stormy webster
[Music]
you're 15 weeks now look
is she moving all right yeah
okay so there's normal amount of fluid
around it
[Music]
it's so crazy
the video was titled to our daughter but
yeah still a surprise
tune in because you never know what's
going to happen and one person who was
happy to hear the news that kylie and
travis swapped out their baby's moniker
wolf van halen the son of legendary
guitarist eddie van halen who weighed in
on twitter writing simply
think [ __ ]
and while fans eagerly wait to find out
the real name of baby number two one
thing we know for sure is the lovebirds
are loving life as a family of four a
source previously told et the two have
wanted to grow their family for a while
now and couldn't be happier
[Music]